ha ha nem azt kapják vagy nem úgy nőnek
fel mert talán már az előddeik sem így
élték meg hogy az élet értékes a te
életed értékes amit mondtál te is erika
hogy ha nem gondolom magam érdemesnek
arra vagy ha nem gondolom magam
értékesnek miért fektetnék bármiféle
erőfeszítést magamba tehát akkor persze
hogy ha nem látom a saját értékem a
saját életem értékét úgy ahogy vagyok és
ez is egy olyan dolog ami egy ilyen egy
ilyen alapelvünk meg amit nagyon
próbálunk a képzésen belül továbbadni
azt hogy értékes vagy de mi viszont
megpróbáljuk alátámasztani ezt amit
mondunk és lehetőséget adun nekik arra
hogy megtapasztalják hogy ez tényleg így
van szóval hogyha nem nem gondolják úgy
hogy ők értékesek akkor persze hogy nem
fognak akarni négy-öt hónapig viszonylag
keményen vagy akár nagyon keményen
dolgozni önmagukért másokért együtt
egyénileg